I'm just really glad the name got set
out loud a few times on the show because
looking at it on paper that's the sort
of spelling that I always go oh god is
it Jerry or Gary continuing my way
through inside number nine the first
season at least I plan to watch more
than that but I'll probably only do
reviews for the first season and we
arrive at Tom and Jerry now this is the
one that's kind of been talked up quite
a bit by folks commenting on my reviews
of this show so far this seems to be one
that is very very highly thought of and
that made me nervous cuz I had I had a
lot of issues with the quiet night in
and I was nervous going to one that I
know is so highly regarded because I
thought oh god if I don't like this one
should I even keep watching this show
was sardines and how much I liked that
was that a fluke
no it wasn't this is this is quite good
I will get into spoilers eventually but
I'll try and stay spoiler free for as
long as I can this was an interesting
thing for me to watch particularly
because of partly because of the
headspace that the previous episode put
me in where I was looking at things that
they were doing obviously just for the
sake of a joke that just really irked me
in terms of depictions of certain types
of people and I got really nervous about
that here because in the initial set up
I feel like I can tell the setup without
counting explosed
so you have a guy named Tom he is he's a
teacher he's an aspiring novelist he
lives in this in this environment that's
flat
it's England so it's a flat with his
girlfriend Jerry who is an actress and
they there's a homeless man outside he
gets referred to as a [ __ ] named Meg
and Tom sort of has an encounter with
him
and then it just sort of goes from there
and I don't want to give too much more
than than that as far as the spoiler
free section goes now I got really
nervous by that because there are a lot
of really troubling depictions of
homeless people in popular entertainment
and given how massive a problem it is
and I I don't know necessarily what the
situations like in England but certainly
how underfunded a lot of these systems
that are attempting to help people who
are living on the streets are in America
at least it it was it was an element I
got very nervous to see was going to be
a major part of this show with this
episode and I think ultimately it was
well handled but I say that more in
terms of the mood tone and direction of
the overall story in terms of specific
things about that character I think
people who really get upset or annoyed
or you know by depictions of homeless
people in in media they may end up still
finding some issue with that and I'm not
gonna say that they're wrong but I will
say there is enough about the episode
answer in terms of tone mood in general
direction of the narrative that for me
made it work um as far as things go it
it it took the curse off it in terms of
how the thing goes through overall this
has one of the more outright sinister
vibes to it from the beginning like Jeff
from the music from the very beginning
to the first time we see make the whole
thing has a creepy vibe to it more out
and out then I've seen from the show so
far
because sardines the creep factor came
in slowly and then at the very end you
know tipped its hand and in a quiet
night in the sort of creepier aspects
just sort of came in tiny
bursts here and there this is much more
front and center which made it kind of
interesting I'd say this is also the
least humorous actually I would say this
one's not even trying to be funny at all
which again puts it in contrast with the
other episodes of the show that I've
seen so far that's not to say that
there's nothing new no no laughs or
nothing fun about it there are a couple
but it's it's the other episodes that
I've seen very deliberately went for
humor for at least a portion of their
runtime this one just really never does
there's like a couple of laughs here and
there but the overall mood is not light
it's not jovial and again with the
direction that things go I think that
was probably a really good call
and I feel like I need to start talking
spoilers so I still think I like
sardines a little better than this but
this is definitely a big step up from a
quiet night in which I really I I think
I just need to pull if I gonna say I
didn't like a quiet night in so now I'm
gonna start getting the spoilers so
obviously I mentioned my concerns about
me being sort of the did some form of a
dangerous hobo and he kind of is but
there are things about the story that
allow me to kind of square that circle
and make that work for me the first is
the overall mood of the piece as a whole
it is never coming across like some sort
of cautionary tale of oh this is what
homeless people are like it never feels
like that the the isolation of the you
know of the single setting helps a lot
because unlike say sardines and a quiet
night in which we're both single
locations set but they also happened
over a continuously shown short period
of time
this happens over weeks but we still
never leave that flat and it gives it a
sense of isolation and heightened
reality that helps
some what would otherwise be problematic
elements about a character like me to go
down a little bit smoother and and for
me at least to work and as things go
along it was funny the other thing is
while this was a thought I had while I'm
watching it I sort of started to see MIG
as a bit of a metaphor for just toxic
gas lighting relationships because I've
seen people in relationships like that
you know whether they were romantic
relationships relationships the head
with friends relationships they have
with coworkers that where somebody just
they drag you down to where they are and
then they climb up on top of you to
stand where you stood and they isolate
you and they cut you off from your
support while playing at being your
friend I mean those sorts of things are
real and then not in a [ __ ] comes and
takes over your flat way that is that is
sort of a heightened exaggerated analogy
or potentially is because by the end
what we're actually dealing with is
we're dealing with a mental illness
story and much like with the homeless
person element if people find that
depiction of mental illness to be
exploitive I again I can't say
definitively you're wrong to feel that
way
and I wouldn't say that I again I feel
like the overall tone is heightened
enough and you know it that it's not
presenting itself as any sort of base
level of reality and while while it is a
little bit sensationalized I do feel
it's over all kind of tackling the whole
concept with a surprising amount of
respect and I think that's part of the
reason that this isn't as jokey an
episode I think they appreciated the
weight of what it was they were actually
doing in terms of dealing with a man's
mental breakdown
as his world kind of came apart and he's
hallucinating and he's having delusions
and he doesn't want to go out and he
doesn't want to see people and he quits
his job and he stops bathing he stopped
shaving and it's a spiral of depression
and isolation exacerbated by Meg
and it was I'm surprised how well the
Jerry twist worked because on paper that
sort of doubled or almost triple twist
that I should be rolling my eyes by the
end of that like the whole thing of you
know meg isn't real just kind of went oh
okay so where were beautiful minding
this all right okay you know I wasn't
shocked by them I did I didn't see it
coming but I wasn't shocked by that
revelation and then when we get Jerry's
a hallucination - I'm like oh man this
guy's really screwed up and then we get
the revealed oh no meg actually was real
but Jerry convinced Tom that he wasn't
and now something awful has happened
it's it's a layering of twists that
should not work but somehow does and I'm
not sure I can pimp or to pinpoint why
it works when I know it shouldn't like
this this just should not work at all
and yet it does somehow and that's kind
of nice it's kind of almost magical it's
like I'm it is like a magic trick
you're just seeing something that I like
wait how did that happen and it's it's
well it's very well acted from all the
people involved from you know the are
are returning main actors to Gemma
Atherton - cannot remember house brows
right now as Jerry and you know we have
Steve who shows up who's nice and as
pleasant and
and and all that works really well and
again anyone who feels it's being
exploitative or reductive in its
depiction of mental illness they I again
I won't say you're wrong but it's it's
detached enough from a sense of reality
that I it works for me as a narrative it
works for me as a storytelling device
and it doesn't have to work for
everybody but it works for me for the
same reason someone like split works for
me it is so far away from selling itself
as being real that something like that
doesn't really bother me so I think that
all about wrap it up yeah this was good
and it makes me feel better about
continuing with the show because yeah
that was a that was a big dip on a quiet
night in but this was this was good
this was well-constructed it's I feel
like to compare to quite night at one
more time this feels really well thought
out a quiet and I didn't felt like it
had well-thought-out logistics in terms
of like the geography of where
characters were at anytime and making
sure they didn't see each other that
part felt felt really well thought out
but moment to moment beat to beat
character moments jokes
felt very lazy this one feels well
thought-out topped ball in a way that
quite night and didn't and I really
appreciated that so I'm gonna wrap it up
there Tom and Jerry inside number nine
have you seen them what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you know the stuff that
you can do and you don't need me to tell
you I do have a preacher on that's kind
of the big one but links for all that
stuff is out in the description and
remember folks you are the council I
just from the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]